so today I'm going to be talking about
covering a package to the aims to bring
test coverage to the our ecosystem my
name is Jim Hester I'm a software
engineer at our studio I worked with
Hadley to write tools that make data
science easier faster and more fun to
use this table is simply showing the
current state of testing in the our
ecosystem across various package
repositories so for the cran repository
there's about 10,000 total packages
about 2,000 of which have tests which
equates to around 20% of the total
packages in crayon with tests at least
some form of testing now in the
bioconductor repository that proportion
is a bit higher about 35% of
bioconductor packages have tests I'll be
it with smaller number of total tests a
little over a thousand total packages
and are open Sai with a much smaller
data set only 150 packages as but has
over 50% of those packages with with
some testing so tests are a focus of the
Arkansas organization so it's good to
see that their their packages aren't
being tested so all told around 23% of
the total packages are being have have
some form of testing so this plot is
showing that's a similar data set over
time so the x-axis has was the time from
January 2002 thousand to today and you
can see the number of packages in the
cran repository so this dataset is only
packages in crammed has been rising
exponentially over that time and is now
nearing 10,000 packages the blue line is
the packages that are have to have at
least some tests
and the red and green line is the blue
line stratified by whether the tests are
using the test that infrastructure or
some other type of testing the framework
this plot is the same data as the
previous plot however now looking at a
proportion of the total number of
packages rather than absolute counts the
blue line is the total number of
packages that are being tested and you
can see it's now over 20% in cran the
red and green line is the data in the
blue line stratified by whether they're
using the test that framework or some
other type of testing framework such as
our unit or an ad hoc framework you can
see that in the past five years or so
the proportion of packages with tests
has been dramatically increasing and
this seems to be largely driven by
characters using tests that for their
testing framework I think this is a very
encouraging plot as it shows that more
and more our packages are being are
including tests which should make for a
much more robust and eco system with
fewer bugs in the future so why do I
think testing is useful firstly for for
package authors to ensure that their
code as as it exists and as they write
it is correct secondly for future
contributions to packages that they do
not break existing behavior and that
they themselves are correct so this is
not only for outside contributions from
other authors but also contributions
from the authors them themselves so from
their future selves
that they don't break existing
functionality when they write new new
functions and lastly for users as sort
of a badge of competence in in a given
package and a way to show package
quality so if a package has tests and a
user can be more confident that there
and that those tests are covering a
large proportion of the package the user
can be more confident that the package
has been well tested and is less less
likely to contain products that they may
run into so test coverage
what is test coverage test coverage is
simply the proportion or lines of your
code of your package code that is
actually ran or tested by your test code
inmate
I'm probably more importantly it is also
the lines of code that are not tested by
your package code so cover is a our
package I I started writing in December
of 2014
it supports local reports of your
testing coverage and interactive use as
well as support for continued use on
continuous integration servers such as
Travis and also Jenkins it supports our
code including s3 s4 reference class and
our six methods which is all of the
primary object oriented systems in our
as well as compiled code in C C++ and
Fortran in in our packages that's
included in in your AR package it also
so up until now we've been talking only
about tests but cover also supports
running on example code as well as
vignette code
so it works not only for your actual
test code but also those are the two
types as well so how this works for our
code is fairly straightforward if we
define a function f with two statements
and then called the trace calls function
on it
cover transforms the the body of the f
function to have two counting statements
and these counting statements can be
used to track exactly what lines or
statements have been executed by that
function so basically what cover does is
takes all the functions in your package
replaces the bodies of the function by
the modified function definition
returned by trace calls and and then
runs your test code on that those not
that modified code you should notice
that the counting calls do not actually
modify the results of any of their the
code that they're tracking so for a more
complicated example well this is a
function with a switch statement you can
see for each condition in the in the
switch each that each one gets its own
counting it's only count call so we can
then easily see exactly which conditions
were executed by by tallying up these
counts so for combined compiled code
cover uses the G cub extension that is
provided in the GCC and clang compilers
and it needs so to enable this you need
to run
you need to compile at your your code
with without optimizations and with the
coverage argument and then you've run
your testing code as normal so what that
does is instruments the compiled code
with coverage information so which can
then be which is output once you once
the process finishes and then can be
aggregated by the GK binary into GK
files which are then parsed by by cover
and and included with the results from
the R code in one homogeneous report so
I mentioned that cover can be used on
Travis and continuous integration
servers so how that works for Travis is
you can add suggest cover to your
package description which will
automatically install cover when testing
on when you're running your code on
Travis and then in the after success
block in your Travis config file you add
either the code cove or coveralls
function call depending on which of
those two services you'd like to use and
then generates you can then include a a
badge and you read me which will make it
easy for users to see exactly how much
coverage your test coverage your package
is using so now I wanted to do a little
demo of showing how easy it is to to set
up testing in your package and and use
cover interactively
all that okay so if we just want to make
a new function make a function add that
simply adds one to a four to a file if
we dev tools is a useful package written
by and maintained by Hadley Wickham who
which contains a function use test which
can be used to add a test file and all
the testing framework you need for a new
package so let's say we can write use
test add which will add our new a new
package or a new test test file so we've
made this function you want to test it
interactively first okay just say add
one add two and this is what everyone
typically does when they write a
function and then test it interactively
so writing a test is very simple you use
the dev tools use test to create the
testing framework and then you just
write expectations for exactly the same
thing that you just did so add one we
expect to be to expect equal to you
expect to be three great and then we can
now run our tests you're using dev tools
test
let me see there's two results both of
which succeeded then if we later want to
change our extend our function to allow
having a second parameter with how much
you want to add
you say add 1 & 2 does equal 3 so now we
can add a new test with that new and run
our tests again and we see oh now our
first two first two tests are now
failing because our new functionality
broke our existing functionality we can
verify that interactively we just add
one oh that equals three instead of two
like we were expecting the reason is our
default was was set incorrectly when we
set up our new on your test so now we
fix that and we have a working test so
this is a great example of how testing
can be beneficial even when you are the
sole developer just adding new
functionality yourself if we now define
a new function let's call this ed even
this well in the what what this will do
is basically add only if
if actually if second input is even
otherwise it will just return the input
so now we can test this I forgot to put
my conditional here's my state s3 okay
now we say it worked all of our tests
succeeded so now if you want to use
cover to see to look at this simple
package the main function you want to
use this package coverage which will
automatically build and test your
package so if you just output the object
that's returned it will give you the
overall coverage for your package so we
see here our overall coverage and also
break it down based on the number of
files in your package so the overall
coverage is 75% we only have one file
which is also 75% you want to look into
this a little further use the report
function and this first generates a
simple report this is actually a table
but we'll skip that for now and you can
look into the file and see exactly which
line is missing coverage so we only
called I'll add even with an even number
you never tried calling it with an odd
number so we have a missing coverage
here so if you wanted to fix that call
it now it's an odd number and we since
it's odd we're not going to actually add
it we're just going to ignore that then
we can run those tests verify they work
it does work and then we run our cover
run the report and then you see now we
have a hundred percent and we had one
these numbers at the end are the number
of times that each line was was ran so
we see we ran this line twice to check
this conditional it went into this
condition once in this condition once
some other useful functions there is a
as data frame method for the coverage
object social output as a data frame you
can see the value is exactly sort of the
same data that we had in our report
it also can aggregate by function so
there's argument to the print method to
be print so by default in groups I file
which isn't very useful in this case
because we only have one file but you
can also group by function and this will
then group the percentages by function
so you can see that we had two functions
both of which are covered a hundred
percent in this case it is I should also
mention it is possible to run cover
without a formal package so if we keep
our hello dot our file but now make a
test file that simply is running our
code
they'll call this test
there's a file coverage function that
simply takes a vector of filenames that
define functions and that run functions
so we'll make our hello hello to our
file which is the file that's defining
all of our functions and our new tests
test out our file that simply runs the
functions then the result we get is
exactly like that which you'd get from a
package we can see again we only ran an
even with an even number so we don't
have any coverage for this odd case so
this is a way to use cover without a
formal package
for a more complicated example will open
the tidy our package written by handy
load cover
again we can use the default print
method of clubs on the coverage object
and that will aggregate the result by
filename we can also route by function
and this will for every pack every
function defined in the package give you
the coverage of that function so this is
an easy way to see exactly which
functions are missing coverage also I'm
going to report on the file which takes
a little bit longer because this is a
more complicated package in this case
you can also sort each of these columns
sortable so you can sort by the number
of missed lines and see the number of
missed lines in the melt CPP file and
you can see in this case Wow here's a
good candidate for additional tests or
these other cases were were checked but
this case was not and since this is a
little bit more complicated logic is
probably useful to check it
another thing we can do is I mentioned
that cover supports not only test
coverage but also example example
coverage so if you run type equals
example it will generate the coverage
for will run all of the code and your
example is internet coverage that way so
this is and then if we print this
coupang by function you can see exactly
which functions don't have examples so
the processing function for instance
does it have any examples written for it
again you can do a report same fashion
looks exactly like it would with the
tests you're just running a different
type of a different set of code on your
package we can see exactly which
functions are ran by your examples
similarly you can do the same thing with
your vignette one thing
the type of vignette will run will
generate will spin the vignettes to
generate a our script and then run that
our script and see exactly which files
or functions are included in the
vignette so this is a good way to see if
there's portions of your package that
maybe you need additional long-form
vignettes for
one last thing I should mention is dev
tools also has a use Travis function
which will set up Travis for you package
and tell you what additional steps you
need to get it working so if you have a
package on github and you would like to
use Travis CI for every time why you
push a change to the package which I I
would encourage well I use use Travis
and there's also a use coverage function
that you can use to set up coverage for
the package and it will tell you exactly
the steps needed to get coverage to get
the badge on your readme and all of that
so those are two functions I recommend
so you'll see how this looks on github
you may have seen these badges so this
is a code coke badge and so the way that
these these are actually signifying that
the package is using cover to generate
its coverage we can click on that it'll
take us the code cub dot IO website this
first plot is showing the coverage over
time so we see coverage of this package
is very steady over in the last six
months right around 92% we can then
drill down into exactly which files do I
do not have coverage so you see in the
our files this extract numeric function
doesn't have coverage in this case I
think it's actually okay this is now a
deprecated function so we probably don't
need to add additional tests that's one
important thing to note is just because
a package to has doesn't have 100
percent coverage doesn't necessarily
mean one that does is is is definitely
better a better solution the just
because a package has test
that run the code doesn't mean it
handles all of the possible inputs so
there could definitely be bugs in a
package even if it has 100% test
coverage we can see this works for
compiled code as well again we can go to
our mount mount C++ function actually
see function and see the same exact
things that the same thing we saw
interactively so this is also a nice way
for users to sort of gauge which package
they'd like to use you see tied er has
92% coverage that's a pretty good
indicator that it's a robust package and
and like they won't have tons of well
you won't run into many bugs with the
package it's just another way leather
metrics someone could use if you don't
typically go to github to look at
packages one nice thing is on the
package landing page at one Crayons
website you click the readme and the
package uses one of the coverage badges
you can see the coverage badge directly
in the readme which and then click on it
to take you to the code cough website
one other nice feature about code code
is it has an extension for chrome that
integrates with github and if package is
using the code cub website service to
track to track coverage it will
automatically annotate the package code
with the coverage for you so you can
easily see oh there's only 70% coverage
in the utilities function and it will
also highlight the code for you so I can
see exactly just when I'm browsing get
home exactly where I'm missing coverage
so this is also one of the reasons I
prefer using code cove on my own project
is is for this extension and some
additional features that it provides
over the coverall service for an example
of the coverall service well here's the
package by Dina Talley he's using
coveralls so if we look at his to be pro
on github it looks very similar to how
it looks with the code code only the
link takes you to the coverall service
instead and this is also very similar to
the interactive ruby port so you can see
all the files in the package well you
can click on one see exactly which
function doesn't have test coverage in
this case it's a printing function so
that's both services are very feature
fall and useful and on you I don't
encourage you to use whichever one you
personally might prefer they're both
fully supported by the cover package
so sort of one last conclusion is our
people actually using this package in
the our eco system so the cover package
so this graph is showing the number of
packages and repositories package
repositories on github that are using
Travis as well as cover with either code
Cove or the coverall service so you can
see from the first sort of release of
when I started writing this package to
today there's well over 1500 packages on
between the two services that are using
that are using cover underneath to do
code coverage for our so that and this
is an edition I should mention the
bioconductor packages they're by
conductor organization runs cover as
part of their nightly build process and
so we have coverage of every package and
with testing on power conductor with the
code come service and they also have
these nice badges on their package
landing pages so we can see the sunrise
experiment package for example has 70%
test coverage
so again this is the number of
repositories on cran but so there's
about over 1500 repositories on github
packages on on github using this like I
said bioconductor is running this on all
of their a thousand packages and so I
think it's and then there's multiple
there's I'm sure a number of additional
package authors who are not using one of
the services on github but are using
cover interactively so there's a large
number of packages using this and this
is just the same plot broken down by
service so originally I only had support
for the coverall service in in the
copper package now there's also support
for food cough and that seems to be a
very popular option and like I said I
prefer by using code clubs for my own
packages what cover is also the focus of
the code covers working group these are
the current members of the working group
and if I need anyone is interested in
joining it you're welcome to do so
primarily the working group has been
focused on sort of bug fixes found in
enterprise use as well as sort of using
cover more in an enterprise setting such
as integration with Jenkins so some
future work is branch coverage so that's
coverage sort of tallying by conditional
statements for each conditional if both
if all the branches are covered the
Intel compiler so right now this support
for GCC and clang but not for the Intel
because it uses a a different mechanism
for tracking and reporting on coverage
Solaris spark system and axe
support right now we only support
Windows Mac OS and Linux and if you're
interested in the code coverage working
group or additional features for cover I
encourage you to join that working group
there's more information at this weak
wiki page and sort of in conclusion
these are all of the sort of useful
functions I think will can be used to
make your package to work with coverage
in your package and track coverage sort
of the most important of which I think
are the package coverage functions the
dev tools functions to set up on
coverage and testing in your package the
report function to generate the
interactive reports some common
questions I get about cover or support
for using on Jenkins so there is now at
least some support for doing that
there's a caberta plugin and Jenkins for
code coverage in Java and we have
support in cover to generate XML files
in that format so you can use that to
integrate with the plug-in and generate
test coverage reports in in your Jenkins
instance some other common questions are
using coverage and testing with shiny
apps I think that's still an ongoing
area of research and experimentation
within our studio
shiny apps because they are interactive
are a little more difficult to test then
other our code but so if you have so
once
so once the sort of story of testing and
shiney is more concretely understood
cover should should work in a similar
way it should work just as well I mean
the
the tricky part is getting the shiny
side of things working but that's
definitely something we're interested in
exploring further in terms of additional
setup for another question that's
commonly asked is some additional setup
requirements for the compiled code
you basically shouldn't have to do
anything additional if you're if you're
our package has compiled code it should
automatically cover should automatically
work automatically detect they're using
compiled code and provide the necessary
arguments so you won't actually have to
do into any additional setup that should
just work out of the box so with that I
think I will thank everyone for watching
this webinar this it unfortunately had
to be re-recorded from the original
webinar because the original recording
did not work but thank you for bearing
with us and if you have any issues with
the cover package I highly encourage you
to open issue on on the github
repository simply my name jim Hester
slash cover slash issue issues on
github.com is the issue you are out with
that thank you for listening and hope
you're use hope you test your package
and use coverage in the future